AS YOU THINK OF THAT ONE.
GREAT SHOW.
BUCKLE UP AND WELCOME TO
"HANNITY."
MASS RAGE, TOTALLY CONSUMING THE
MODERN DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST
PARTY.
OF COURSE AFTER PRESIDENT TRUMP
WAS VINDICATED BY ROBERT MUELLER
AND FOR THE LEFT IT IS LIKE A
LECTURE 2016 ALL OVER AGAIN
BECAUSE FOR TWO YEARS DEMOCRATS
ALONG WITH THEIR PARTNERS IN THE
MEDIA MOB OR PUMPING UP THEIR
BASE.
THEY GOT GIDDY AND PRAISE THEIR
HERO ROBERT MUELLER BECAUSE THEY
WERE FINALLY GOING TO GET
DONALD TRUMP.
THE EXIT POLLS SHOWED HE WAS
GOING TO LOSE AND THEY WERE
WRONG.
THE FACTS OF REALITY GOT IN THE
WAY BECAUSE THERE NEVER WAS
COLLUSION, NOPE CONSPIRACY, NO
OBSTRUCTION FROM TRUMP AND HIS
CAMPAIGN FOR NOT DEMOCRATS ARE
DEFLATED AND THEY ARE HEADING
LEVELS OF DELUSION WITH RECKLESS
FANTASIES ABOUT IMPEACHMENT AND
DOING EVERYTHING THEY CAN
POSSIBLY DO TO HARASS, EVEN USE
THE IRS AGAINST A SITTING
PRESIDENT.
WE ARE EXPOSING IT PIECE BY
PIECE AND WE ARE ALSO GOING TO
BE ASKING THE MOST IMPORTANT
UNANSWERED QUESTIONS.
THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF THEM.
WE ARE GIVING YOU THE TOP ONCE
MIKE WANTED ROBERT MUELLER KNOW
THERE WAS NO COLLUSION, NO
COORDINATION?
WHY WEREN'T WE TOLD?
WHY DID THEY HOLD THAT BACK AND
IF THEY KNEW THERE WAS NO CRIME
ON THE LONG EARLY ON IN THE
INVESTIGATION, WHY NOT LET THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, WE THE PEOPLE
KNOW?
TO REVEAL TO WE THE PEOPLE THAT
THIS WAS ALL BASED ON A SERIES
OF FALSE NARRATIVES AND PHONY
ALLEGATIONS LIKE THE STEELE
DOSSIER.
WHAT DIDN'T THEY INVESTIGATE
THIS WHICH WAS LIKE A FINAL NAIL
DRILLED IN THE COFFIN BY ROBERT
MUELLER.
"IN THE WAKE OF THE MUELLER
REPORT QUESTION IS NOT WHETHER
THE DOSSIERS STRUCTURES WERE
ACCURATE BUT WHY WERE THEY SO
WRONG?"
EVEN OUR FRIEND BOB WOODWARD IS
ACKNOWLEDGING THE PROBLEMS WITH
CLINTON'S BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
RUSSIAN LIES USED IN THE
ELECTION.
GUESS BETTER LATE THAN NEVER.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> EARLY IN BUILDING THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY
ASSESSMENT ON RUSSIAN
INTERFERENCE, AN EARLY DRAFT
THEY ACTUALLY PUT THE DOSSIER ON
PAGE TWO AND KIND OF A BREAKOUT
BOX.
I THINK IT WAS THE CIA PUSHING
THIS REAL INTELLIGENCE EXPERTS
LOOKED AT THIS AND SAID THIS IS
NOT INTELLIGENCE.
THIS IS GARBAGE AND I TOOK IT
OUT.
IN THIS PROCESS THE IDEA THAT
THEY WOULD INCLUDE SOMETHING
LIKE THAT IN ONE OF THE GREATEST
DOLLAR INTELLIGENCE ASSESSMENTS
AS MUELLER ALSO FOUND OUT IS
HIGHLY QUESTIONABLE.
IT NEEDS TO BE INVESTIGATED.
>> Sean: HIGHLY QUESTIONABLE.
BOB, WE HAD AN ENSEMBLE TEAM FOR
OVER TWO YEARS WILL BENT ON
PEELING THE LAYERS AFTER LAYER
AFTER LAYER OF THE BIGGEST ABUSE
OF POWER CORRUPTION SCANDAL IN
OUR HISTORY.
THIS ENSEMBLE CAST ON RADIO AND
TV AND MY SHOW HAD BEEN RIGHT
ALL ALONG AND NOW
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," EVEN THEY
ARE COMING TO TERMS WITH SOME
DOSE OF REALITY REVEALING IN A
NEW PIECE AT THE DOSSIER IS NOW
UNDER RENEWED SCRUTINY T.
BABY STEPS FOR THEM.
THE MEDIA MAY HAVE BEEN MORE
WRONG THAN WE THOUGHT.
ACCORDING TO THE TIMES, THE
DOSSIER MAY HAVE BEEN A PART OF
A RUSSIAN CAMPAIGN TO BEGIN WIT
WITH.
HILLARY'S CAMPAIGN, SHE PAID FOR
IT.
NOT TO HELP DONALD TRUMP BUT TO
SET UP LANDMINES AND SO CHAOS
AND DISCORD AMONG THE AMERICAN
ELECTORAL RATE.
JOHN SOLOMON WILL JOIN US IN A
FEW MOMENTS TO EXPLAIN MORE TO
YOU BUT ASK YOURSELF, WHEN WILL
THE FAKE NEWS MEDIA MOB
APOLOGIZE FOR THEIR LIES AND
CONSPIRACY THEORIES?
WHEN WILL THEY TAKE
ACCOUNTABILITY?
WHEN WILL THEY TAKE ACCOUNT FOR
FUELING COLLUSION, HYSTERIA,
BREATHLESS REPORTING?
FACTS WERE ONLY AN AFTERTHOUGHT,
ANY ANONYMOUS SOURCE THEY
BELIEVED LIKE BUZZFEED, THE
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT HAVING THE
PRESIDENT'S ALLY WHICH IS
TOTALLY FALSE FOR NPR BEING
EMBARRASSED AFTER LIED ABOUT
DON JR.'S TESTIMONY.
OR BLATANTLY WRONG ABOUT MICHAEL
COHEN'S TRIP TO PRAGUE.
IT NEVER HAPPENED.
THE GUARDIAN REPORTED A FAKE
CONSPIRACY ABOUT JULIAN MASSAGE.
THREE CNN EMPLOYEES FORCED TO
RESIGN AFTER REPORTING AND
UNTRUE RUSSIAN RELATED STORY
ABOUT OUR FRIEND, ANTHONY
SCARAMUCCI.
BRIAN ROSS LEAVING ABC AFTER A
FAKE NEWS STORY THAT ACTUALLY
IMPACTED NEGATIVELY THE STOCK
MARKET.
IT WAS FAKE HYSTERIA ABOUT A
RUSSIAN SPY IN THE WHITE HOUSE
FOR BLOOMBERG FORCED TO CORRECT
THEIR STORY ABOUT TRUMP IN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" WALKING
CLAIMS BACK ABOUT PAUL MANAFORT
SHARING POLLING DATA WITH THE
RUSSIAN OLIGARCH.
DON'T FORGET
"THE WASHINGTON POST" HAVING TO
CORRECT THEIR STORY ABOUT
RUSSIANS HACKING OVER UTILITY
WHICH WASN'T TRUE.
EVERY SECOND, EVERY HOUR, FAKE
STORY AFTER FAKE STORY, LIE
AFTER LIE, CONSPIRACY AFTER
CONSPIRACY THEORY.
RATHER THAN TAKE RESPONSIBILITY
FOR ALL OF THESE FAILURES, AND
EPIC FAIL THE MEDIA IS SINKING
TO NEW LOWS.
DOUBLING DOWN ON LIES AND
STUPID.
LOOK AT HOW A SO-CALLED REPORTER
AT NBC NEWS LITERALLY AMBUSHED
ROBERT MUELLER AS HE IS LEAVING
EASTER SERVICES.
THESE PEOPLE HAVE NO SHAME.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> CAN I ASK YOU A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS?
WILL YOU TESTIFY BEFORE CONGRES
CONGRESS?
>> NO COMMENT.
>> WITH MR. TRUMP HE INDICTED?
WHY DIDN'T YOU MAKE A
RECOMMENDATION TO CONGRESS ONE
WAY OR THE OTHER?
DID THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
ACCURATELY CHARACTERIZE YOUR
POSITIONS ON CONSPIRACY AND
OBSTRUCTION?
>> Sean: COULD WE MAKE
CHURCHES OUT-OF-BOUNDS?
THE MEDIAS NEGLIGENCE, SO MANY
UNANSWERED QUESTIONS.
THIS IS REALLY ONLY THE FIRST
CHAPTER AND WHAT MUST BE A
RECKONING FOR THE COUNTRY.
IF THIS COUNTRY IS TO SURVIVE IT
IS THAT SERIOUS, WE WILL SHINE
THE LIGHT NOW ON THE TEN BIGGEST
AND THERE ARE HUNDREDS
UNANSWERED QUESTIONS.
WENT TO THE FBI FIRST REALIZED
THAT A DOSSIER WAS BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR BY HILLARY CLINTON AND
IF THEY KNEW IT, WHY DIDN'T HE
INVESTIGATE THAT WHEN THEY'RE
INVESTIGATING A WHOLE ISSUE OF
RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE?
HOW MUCH EVIDENCE THEY HAVE
ABOUT GEORGE PAPADOPOULOS,
CARTER PAGE AND DID THEY HIDE
THAT INFORMATION FROM THE FISA
COURT?
WE HAVE A QUESTION FOR JAMES
COMEY, WHY DID HE SAY FIND THE
FISA WARRANT, IT WAS THE
DOSSIER, WHY DID HE SIGN IT
WHICH MEANS HE APPROVED IT
ASSUMING IT'S VERIFIED IN
OCTOBER 2016 AND TELL TRUMP THE
PRESIDENT-ELECT, IT IS SALACIOUS
BUT UNVERIFIED?
BY THE WAY, WHY WERE THE
ANTI-TRUMP BIASES HID FROM THE
FISA COURT?
LIKE HILLARY BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
THAT IN BIG BOLD LETTERS.
WHY WERE THEY LEAKING DETAILS ON
THE RUSSIA PROBE BEFORE EVER
COOPERATING ANYTHING TO DO WITH
COLLUSION?
NEXT QUESTION, DID JAMES COMEY'S
HANDLE CLASSIFIED INFORMATION
WITH LEAKING MEMOS FROM HIS
PRIVATE CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
PRESIDENT?
HERE'S A BIG ONE.
LET'S GO TO THE OBAMA
WHITE HOUSE.
FOOTED SUSAN RICE, SAMANTHA
POWERS, LORETTA LYNCH, WHAT DID
THEY KNOW AND WHEN DID THEY KNOW
IT?
WHAT DID OBAMA KNOW AND WHEN DID
HE KNOW RIGHT IF AS PAGE AND A
STRZOK ARE SAYING THEY WERE
RUNNING IT FROM THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT?
CIA OR FBI, DID THEY ENGAGE OR
SIGN OFF ON SURVEILLANCE AGAINST
A TRUMP TEAM TO SPY ON THEM
BEFORE OPENING THE SO-CALLED
INVESTIGATION.
IN OTHER WORDS, DID THEY BYPASS
AMERICAN LAWS ABOUT ABUSING
INTELLIGENCE AND USING THE
WEAPONS OF INTELLIGENCE AGAINST
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND
OUTSOURCE THAT TO FRIENDLY
ALLIES AND GET INFORMATION THEY
WOULDN'T OTHERWISE GET?
MAY BE PLACES LIKE THE U.K. TO
GATHER EVIDENCE ON THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN OR MAYBE AUSTRALIA OR
ITALY.
TO THE CIA TRY TO PRESSURE OF
THE FBI IN OPENING A TRUMP
COLLUSION PROBE BEFORE THE
ELECTION?
IF WE DO NEED TO KNOW
CONSIDERING IT WAS SO IMPORTANT,
ISSUES LIKE LOAN APPLICATIONS,
TAXES AND MEDALLIONS, WELLS LIE
TO CONGRESS?
WE KNOW ANDREW McCABE IS BEING
THERE FOR A FALSE TESTIMONY BUT
HE ALSO SAID NO DOSSIER, NO FISA
WARRANT.
HIS TESTIMONY CONTRADICTS THAT
OF GLEN SIMPSON AT FUSION GPS.
SOMEBODY LIED I DID ALL
CONFLICTS WITH WHAT BRUCE OHR
SAID.
LET'S GO BACK TO LORETTA LYNCH,
WHAT DID SHE KNOW AND WHAT DID
KNOW WHAT?
WE ARE INCHING CLOSER AND CLOSER
TO JUSTICE, THERE IS NO STOPPING
THIS ABUSE OF POWER AND
CORRUPTION FROM BEING EXPOSED.
THAT I CAN PROMISE YOU TONIGHT.
IT IS TIME FOR TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY.
IF WE CANNOT LET THIS HAPPEN IN
OUR COUNTRY.
MY SOURCES ARE TELLING ME, IT IS
ALL COMING SOON.
IT IS TIME TO DECLASSIFY THOSE
FISA APPLICATIONS, WE STILL HAVE
THE IG HORWITZ, HE IS EXPECTED
LATER THIS SPRING WITH HIS
REPORT ON FISA ABUSE.
THE GANG OF EIGHT MATERIAL,
LET'S SEE IT ALL.
DEMOCRATS WANT TRANSPARENCY,
OKAY, ABSOLUTELY.
LET'S EXPOSE THE BIGGEST ABUSE
OF CORRUPTION IN OUR HISTORY.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WILL BE
SHOCKED.
LET'S EXPOSE THE NEW RADICAL
PARTY, STILL HELL-BENT ON
SPREADING LIES EVERY SECOND,
EVERY HOUR OF EVERY DAY.
A PUBLIC TRIAL.
WHEN THE DEMOCRATS AREN'T
FUELING THEIR UNHINGED HYSTERIA,
LET NOT YOUR HEARTS BE TROUBLED
BECAUSE THEIR COHORTS IN THE
HATE TRUMP MEDIA MOB PICK UP THE
SLACK.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IF THE MAIN CONCERN HERE IS
THAT HE IS NOT GOING TO BE
CONVICTED BY THE SENATE
DEMOCRATS MAY BE MAKING A BAD
POLITICAL CALCULATION.
THIS QUALITY REPORT WAS A DOG.
IT HAS A LOT IN IT.
>> I STILL HOPE THAT IN THIS DAY
AND AGE REPUBLICANS WILL SEE THE
FACTS AND WILL BE AS APPALLED AS
DEMOCRATS ARE.
THIS REPORT WAS COMPLETELY
EXPOSING OF UNFIT IMPEACHABLE
BEHAVIOR.
>> AN INNOCENT MAN DOES NOT
SCREECH AND COMPLAIN.
>> WHY HAVEN'T YOU OPENED AN
IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY OR IS THAT
WHAT YOU'RE DOING DOING RIGHT
NOW?
>> IMPEACHMENT GETS POLITICIZED
SO YOU HAVE A LEGAL CASE THAT
YOU BELIEVE THIS HAPPENS AND YOU
SHOULD DO IT BUT THE POLITICS
DICTATE SOMETHING ELSE.
HOW THAT INFLUENCE THIS
DECISION?
IS THIS A NANCY PELOSI'S HANDS?
>> Sean: WE KNOW DEMOCRATS
AREN'T INTERESTED IN THE TRUTH.
NANCY PELOSI DOWNPLAYING
IMPEACHMENT.
WRITING THERE ARE OTHER WAYS TO
HOLD THE PRESIDENT ACCOUNTABLE.
SHE IS SCARED TO DEATH WHAT THIS
WITCH HUNT WILL MEAN FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND HER POWER.
THE SENTIMENTS AND A CALL TODAY,
THAT IS NOT STOPPING THE RADICAL
BASE OF THE NEW EXTREME RADICAL
SOCIALIST DEMOCRATIC PARTY BY
COLLUSION TRUTH.
THE BIGGEST LIAR OF THEM ALL.
ADAM SCHEFTER SANDY REPORT
PROVED HIM RIGHT.
IF YOU CAN MAKE THIS STUFF UP
AND I WILL SAY IT AGAIN, YOU ARE
WELCOME ON THE SHOW ANYTIME YOU
WANT A FULL HOUR AND I WILL GIVE
YOU THREE HOURS OF MY RADIO SHOW
IF YOU WOULD LIKE, 650 STATIONS
AND A BIG AUDIENCE.
CONGRESSMAN, YOU ARE WELCOME ANY
TIME.
THAT GOES FOR THE REST OF THEM
IF THEY WANT TO BE A PART OF IT.
AS WE CONTINUE ALONG, ANYBODY
THAT WANTS TO BE A PART OF THIS
PROGRAM WE WILL EXPOSE THE LIES
THAT PEOPLE LIKE THEM.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT?
HOW MUCH HURTING YOUR DOING FOR
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THE REAL COLLUDED IN ALL OF THIS
IS ONLY ONE PERSON AND VIA
EVIDENCE, COMEDIC GOLD.
HERE'S THIS ON TAPE.
>> SHE MET WITH TRUMP.
ALSO KNOWN AS A PERSON WITH A
STRANGE REPUTATION.
>> HOW DO YOU SPELL HER NAME?
>> WHAT IS THE NATURE OF THE
COMPROMISE?
VLADIMIR PUTIN WAS MADE AWARE OF
THE AVAILABILITY OF THE
COMPROMISING MATERIAL?
>> YES OF COURSE.
>> WE WILL BE BACK IN TOUCH WITH
YOU THROUGH OUR STAFF TO MAKE
ARRANGEMENT TO OBTAIN THESE
MATERIALS FOR COMMITTEE AND FOR
THE FBI AND I APPRECIATE YOU
REACHING OUT TO US.
>> Sean: WHAT IS THE NATURE OF
THE COMPROMISE?
DID VLADIMIR PUTIN SEE IT?
>> OF COURSE.
HE SEE IT.
IF YOU CAN MAKE THIS STUFF UP.
WE HAVE DEVIN NUNES, WE WARNED
ABOUT RUSSIA AND VLADIMIR PUTIN,
HOSTILE ACTORS ON THE WORLD
STAGE.
DEVIN NUNES WANT THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION IT ALL HAPPENED
ON THEIR WATCH THAT THIS WOULD
HAPPEN IN 2016.
SAYS WHO THEY ARE AND WHAT THEY
DO AND AFTER 30 PLUS YEARS AFTER
OUR GOVERNMENT BEING HACKED, CAN
WE PLEASE BUILD DEFENSES TO BE
ON HABITABLE?
WE SHOULD ALL BE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE INTEGRITY OF OUR ELECTIONS
AND THE FACT THAT THIS
GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN HACKED
REPEATEDLY FOR DECADES BY
HOSTILE REGIMES.
WE NEED A TOP TO BOTTOM KILLER
DEFENSE PROCEDURE AGAINST THESE
HACKERS.
THAT IS WHY HILLARY CLINTON'S
EMAIL SERVER IS A REAL THREAT TO
OUR SAFETY AND SECURITY.
WE BELIEVE THAT PLACE WAS PACKED
BY SIX FOREIGN ENTITIES.
THIS WAS ALL WEAPONIZED IN THE
PRESS, ANY DEEP STATE TO
BLUDGEON DONALD TRUMP.
A BEHIND THE CURTAIN LIE, IT IS
TIME TO INVESTIGATE THE
INVESTIGATORS.
THAT MEANS HILLARY CLINTON AND
THE FACT THAT THAT INVESTIGATION
WAS RIGGED AND THEN THEY TRY TO
READ THE PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION
AND UNDO A DULY ELECTED
PRESIDENT.
THE MEDIA WAS ALL THERE.
LET'S STICK TO THE FACTS AND NOT
RUSH TO JUDGMENT.
MAY BE THE MEDIA CONSULT REFLECT
AND NOT JUMP ON THE NEXT STORY,
ESPECIALLY COMMON SENSE AMERICA
WAKE UP TO THEIR LIES AND SMEAR
SMEARS.
THEY ATTACKED HIM WITH MORE AND
LESS INVESTIGATIONS AND
ANONYMOUS SOURCES AND THANKFULLY
HE IS FIGHTING BACK.
HE FILED A LAWSUIT AGAINST THE
DEMOCRATS LATEST ON IT AND HOW
THEY WANT TO EMBOLDEN THE IRS
AND RELEASE HIS TAXES EXPLAINING
THAT THE PLOY HAS NO LEGITIMATE
PURPOSE.
NOT ONCE DID HE INVOKE EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE.
EVEN THE WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL 30
HOURS BEFORE MUELLER.
TO SEE WHAT IS GOING ON?
THEY ARE OUT OF IDEAS.
THEY SINK TO A PSYCHOTIC LOW AND
THIS IS ALL THEY THINK ABOUT.
WHEN THEY ARE NOT PUSHING AND
LESS INVESTIGATIONS, NONSTOP FAR
LEFT SOCIALISM OR BLUDGEONING A
16-YEAR-OLD KID.
YOU WANT TO SEE RADICAL
SOCIALISM?
LOOK AT THE MAYOR OF
NEW YORK CITY ANNOUNCING TO PAN
AN EFFICIENT STEEL AND GLASS
SKYSCRAPERS FROM THE WORK!
RETRO FRUIT IN EVERY BIG
BUILDING IN NEW YORK.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE BIGGEST SOURCE OF THE
MISSIONS NEW YORK CITY IS BUILD
THINGS.
WE ARE PUTTING CLEAR AND STRONG
MANDATES, THE FIRST OF ANY CITY
ON EARTH TO SAY YOU HAVE TO
CLEAN UP YOUR ACT AND SAVE
ENERGY.
IF YOU DON'T DO IT BY 2030 THERE
WILL BE SERIOUS FINES.
WE WILL BAN THE CLASSIC GLASS
AND STEEL SKYSCRAPERS WHICH ARE
INCREDIBLY INEFFICIENT.
IF SOMEBODY WANTS TO BUILD ONE,
WE WILL NOT ALLOW WHAT WE SEE IN
THE PAST.
>> Sean: HOW WILL HE BUILD
THOSE?
YOU CAN'T BUILD THOSE WITH
TIMBER BECAUSE NOT BE KILLING A
TREE.
NO CARS, NO ENGINES, NO PLANES
BUT EVERYTHING IS FREE.
THEY DON'T EVEN MEET THESE